all right this is going to be a fun one
maybe a little divisive too maybe
depends on which side of the argument
you fall but at any rate my experience
watching the live action yuu Haka show
was utterly fascinating and given that
I've recently watched through the entire
liveaction one piece Netflix series 2
these two Productions combined have
given me hope that we are on the cusp of
a flood of genuinely faithful compelling
and expertly produced adaptations to our
favorite manga from the East now that's
not to say that both of these shows are
perfect because trust me they sure have
their flaws plenty of them but I think
what I've taken away from these
adaptations is that they have a lot to
learn from one another many of the
aspects that yuu Haka Show's live action
came up short on one piece excelled in
and vice versa and as a result it's
become clear to me that a genuinely
excellent allrounder adaptation is not
only possible but surely imminent so if
you haven't already seen the live action
YuYu Haka show or one piece adaptations
on Netflix then I highly encourage you
to do so before pushing forward with
this video as there will be tons of
spoilers however if you don't care about
spoilers or just don't like being told
what to do then great because man do I
have a lot to talk about
today YuYu hoaky Show episode one by the
time I got done watching this episode I
was convinced I was watching something
truly special I even tweeted as much
citing that if this standard had been
retained across the remainder of the
series then we could very well be
looking at an all-time best in this sub
genre with any adaptation the first
question I think any Creator let alone f
asks is what approach is being taken
here this is a five episode series and
yuu Haka show is a story that famously
takes a little while to get going one
piece live action largely kept itself
structurally faithful instead truncating
arcs to fit in eight individual episodes
with varying success one glance at the
poster makes it clear yuu Haka show is
going to cover a lot of material across
its short runtime and as it turns out
the way it wants to do that is to
combine plot points from across the
series to tell its own version of a
events the first two episodes flew by
they were the definition of all killer
no filler and I mean that in the best
possible way but I think this will
understandably give pause to anyone
looking for a straight adaptation most
everything that is skipped over or
reformatted is done so in service of
fitting the story into five episodes of
runtime some good some less so the
condensation of the manga's first Arc
Kara's introd well okay everyone's
introduction actually is all pretty darn
well well done we are delivered these
characters Essence in an extremely
timely manner in the case of kabara and
Bolan the characters are written and
acted to great effect and really do feel
like the manga characters brought to
life some of this reformatting hits a
little bit less well though naturally in
an attempt to quickly showcase yusuke's
good side he has shown ardently
defending a bullied kid and taking the
fall when authority figures show up mid
altercation that in and of itself is not
bad necessarily but the show doesn't
really do much to show us any of
yusuke's more delinquent personality so
it feels especially odd when any other
character talks about him as such
ultimately though alongside these
changes there are still loads of
onetoone Recreations and beats like
yusuke getting hit by the car to save
the kid the funeral Etc that all managed
to hit the mark in
Spades the most dramatic departure comes
prior to Yuk's Revival in the second
half where it starts to pull from parts
of the manga significantly later down
the line normally when an adaptation
tries to Cobble together disperate
moments to try and streamline The
Narrative you get avatar The Last
Airbender the movie despite taking
elements from all over though this
initial episode doesn't fall victim to
the same fate yusuke learns how to use
the ray gun kabara is characterized
through shared struggles with his
classmates Koo has her pyromaniac moment
and of course this whole segment is
stitched together using the zombie Trope
that kicks off the chapter black
material in spite of all of this being
woven together in such a short time
frame
I actually think they managed to create
a cohesive character focused story with
kickass action that just felt right
there's certainly something to be said
about the edge of your seed uncertainty
that comes with reimagined territory but
despite me being well aware of where the
story ends up you could have caught the
tension with a knife with the climax of
this first episode and then we got to
episode two and the epicness just kept
on
trucking
[Music]
you've no doubt seen this gouki versus
yusuke fight do the rounds on social
media since the show's launch and it's
for good reason in all honesty the
action in this show is Far and Away its
strongest asset and it shouldn't be a
surprise to anyone familiar with the
rudoi Kenshin liveaction movies the
action director of its initial three a
guy by the name of takahito OI is the
very same director at the Helm of the
action here I have no idea how this guy
does it but his masterfully
choreographed work just feels Larger
than Life in the best kind of way it
hearkens back to those classic woa
movies that have served as countless
Inspirations for anime action so it
wrapping back around here is honestly
awesome one piece live action's action
was pretty damn well choreographed too
but unfortunately I think where it
stumbled for me was how the show was
shot and edited you can have the
greatest choreograph action in the world
but if the cinematography is lacking
it's just not going to land in a
convincing way there's a saying in film
making that drama is shot in closeup
while comedy is shot in
wide a huge majority of One Piece was
shot with extremely wide angle lenses
and natural light with the camera often
at an awkwardly framed distance the
speed and authenticity of it all seldom
landed for me as a result and I think
it's interesting to look at yuu Haka
shows in comparison to find some obvious
ways to improve this show was shot by
Kos Yamada who's probably most famously
known for serving as is the Director of
Photography for shin Godzilla having a
premium dop like that is a huge asset
and this guy knew how to frame this
action to Perfection with camera lenses
there's something called focal length
that effectively defines the field of
view small focal lengths create huge
wide angles that fit a lot in but have a
lot of distortion and are generally why
you hate your phone selfies a majority
of films will go with high or medium
focal lengths because it just results in
a more professional and Balan looking
frame
when Studios do eventually use wide
angle lengths it's typically for effect
like a Trippy drug sequence or a means
to throw the viewer off kilter one
piece's live action used wide angle
effectively nonstop the camera is
constantly distorting faces or framing
action with these huge sweeping angles
and I totally get the intent anime is
chucked full of this stuff and I imagine
the idea was to try to bring that to
life but I don't think the idea
translated as well as many might have
thought and it ended up looking quite
amateur at the worst of times if you
look at these phenomenally well-shot yuu
Haka show sequences you can see all of
this perfectly cinematic framing that
knows when to go handheld when to use
Crane and or Dolly and when to use a
wide angle for momentary effect it's a
carefully considered piece with a
tremendously well-lit and color graded
aesthetic to boot now don't get me wrong
this video isn't just going to be me
singing YuYu haker Show's Praises while
criticizing one pieces both of these
shows have tremendous production design
the Practical sets were always going to
be e iier for a grounded show like yuu
Haka show that has the whole real life
Tokyo to use but even still it was great
to see that kenma's Palace was a built
set much like one piece as baradia was
although I don't know if kenma's green
screen looker quite sold me
unfortunately the conclusion to this
wonderful episode left me with a feeling
of unease suddenly introducing
characters like sakio yukina and he in
quick succession and unfortunately that
jarring moment of fast forward pacing
establishes a trend and marks an end of
of the Brilliance of these first two
opening
episodes episode 3 aka the worst episode
all right all right the action is great
you get the idea unfortunately this
episode is the series's low point and it
drastically hurts the potential of this
series going forward adapting multiple
pieces of vital story can be possible if
carried out with the mission of being in
service to the characterization at ARS
in question I mean that's exactly what
episodes one and even two did to a
lesser extent but from this point
onwards it felt as though the series
cared less about meaningfully adapting
segments in creative ways to heighten
the characters and instead just wanted
to stuff in as many memorable scenes as
they possibly could so that people could
say oh hey look it's that thing from y
you Haka show One Piece live action
certainly made its fair share of cuts
some of which I wished weren't removed
like the action on the barad or how
mihawk showed up in the manga but
despite that Netflix's one piece
remained remarkably consistent all
throughout the season it was telling
while elements were cut you could tell
they weren't racing towards a specific
conclusion and offered plenty of
opportunity for us to bond with the
characters during intimate moments of
reprieve it understood that multiple
Seasons would be needed to tell the
story properly and if it didn't get to
renew then so be it at least they
honored the structure of the original
story YuYu Haka show by contrast doesn't
seem to care about or even want more
seasons episode 3 is a hardcut to
training with Genai introducing tog Gro
throwing Dark Tournament plot points at
the wall and blending it all with he's
establishing beats 2 all of that
well-crafted combination of points from
the First episodes flies out the window
in favor of a vapid Greatest Hits
Montage I don't hate the idea of
introducing he through the assault in
teran's mension as it offers a speedy
opportunity to establish yukina and his
attachment there I don't hate the idea
of blending aspects of the Dark
Tournament into the yukina rescue Arc
either necessarily on paper I can
absolutely Envision a world in which
this works as a unique take on the YuYu
haaka show story but in reality it
really just feels like shortcuts made
out of a misguided foundational belief
that a successful season 1 just had to
cover the most popular part of the story
the most pivotal failing of episode 3
specifically even beyond all of the
other Insanity crammed within it is its
handling of Gen Kai she is introduced in
episode 3 immediately given Yus G kabara
with no real attachment does very little
in the way of actual training with them
and is then killed off all within one
episode the entire episode completely
neuters and annihilates any audience
attachment to Gen Kai where she was a
deeply important figure to yusuke in the
Manga and Anime here she just feels like
well some old lady that taught yusuke to
shoot this spirit gun better while
tabara beat a stick against a rock alone
and then she died that alone is already
very problematic but the issues deepen
and Cascade out of control as we reach
episodes four and five and begin to see
how important Gen Kai actually was to
this
story episodes four and 5 AKA look how
they massacred my boy fortunately these
episodes aren't a total wash and I think
it's important to highlight what they
did very right before I weep into this
microphone and fight a break down all
over the things they did wrong when it
comes to live action adaptations of
comics and manga I think there's often a
temptation to remove all semblance of
comedy and fun from The Source instead
retooling it into a dark and gritty
cinematic take which you know honestly
sometimes that's a totally valid
interpretation of the source if it has
many versions of the characters like
Batman and Superman do but with manga
and YuYu Haka show especially the source
is the source the characters are the
characters and their mix of serious and
Goofy is a pivot and awesome part of the
whole experience this adaptation 100%
gets that and doesn't even remotely shy
away from ensuring this is funny as
hell there's copious amounts of campy
physical comedy there's subtle little
background bits of Comedy that elevate
character and then there's just pure
childish
hilarity this show genuinely had me
laughing out loud multiple times and
it's so refreshing to to see an
adaptation stay true to its roots in
this department and perhaps somewhat
divisively one of the funnier elements
comes from how the show actually departs
from a faithful depiction of a certain
character the Elder toguro is Far and
Away the biggest highlight in this final
stretch Kenichi tako's portrayal of this
character is beyond hysterical he dials
up the creepy campiness to 11 and
commits like no other I've seen just the
facial expressions alone are funny
enough but man the staging of this
character as he crawls along the walls
like a madman had me roaring with
laughter at times it's such a total 180
of the manga's version that I probably
should be upset but the performance is
way too hilariously unhinged for me to
even care even a little at this point
particularly after so much had been
changed
already sadly I wish I could say that
the departures across the other
characters worked for me quite as well
the advantages of yuu Haku shows real IC
and grounded World which allows brawls
in the city streets of Japan rather than
the fictional and demanding world of One
Piece really worked against characters
like he and Kurama in an ironic twist of
fate that sense of grounded identity
this yuu Haka show adaptation possessed
really clashed with their I don't know
very anime costuming and design he's
design is certainly not one that's easy
to translate convincingly into live
action in the first place but that
difficulty is made all the worse as it
clashes against the more pragmatic
approach to the rest of the cast most
characters look like they're wearing
normal clothing and here comes he
looking more like the liveaction
embodiment of Lincoln Park's Hybrid
Theory album and look hey it's a great
album but uh I wouldn't exactly be
asking for fashion tips the same as
doubly or maybe even quadruply true of
Kurama who is the most wig wearing wig
person to have ever wigged it's all just
you don't know well it's rough to look
at and regrettably feels out of place in
this production and for the two most
straightforward and stoic characters to
look the most silly it really clashes
with the atmosphere their characters are
trying to achieve which isn't exactly
something you want to say about
characters that are meant to be Central
to the story now a large component of
what made one piece's live action Garner
the Goodwill it did across the online
sphere was his dedication to telling the
story we all loved and finding the right
actors to play the respective roles must
have been an exceptionally difficult
task however despite some of them being
more Rough Around the Edges than others
on an acting front the cast of One Piece
didn't even need to stick 100% to the
story of these early arcs to feel like
the characters themselves Emily Rudd
felt like Nami maken Yu felt like Zoro
inaki Godoy was Luffy he was L seriously
what the hell how do they find this guy
one piece has some of the weirdest most
out there and tough toast characters but
in the end they all fell true to the
entities they were portraying which is a
miracle if nothing else I would say that
as acting goes yuu Haka show probably
held a higher standard overall some of
those early moments of Koo and yusuke's
mother grieving were genuinely moving
and while they absolutely nailed the
casting and characterization for the
likes of kabara and Bolan I couldn't
help but feel like they missed the mark
with the direction and script they gave
to takumi kitamura yusuke ureshi the
main character while looking the part
and well in some scenes with kuara they
look honestly exactly like their manga
counterparts to a creepy extent takumi's
portrayal of yusuke fell I don't know
quite one note yusuke in the anime and
manga is quite the emotional kid he's
Moody and aloof yes but he's also by his
very nature extremely expressive and
emotional you can't go two pages in the
manga without him whiplashing from
emotion to emotion wearing those
feelings on his sleeve and face for all
to see yusuke is brooding goofy curious
aloof angry happy and everything in
between but live action yusuke well you
know when your parents used to say that
you shouldn't make goofy faces because
one day you might pull one and you get
stuck like that well clearly this juice
game made a very grumpy uninterested
face as a child that has been stuck like
that ever since it's honestly a real
bummer because the team behind this show
are clearly capable of writing
characters full of life and range their
characterization of kabara alone proves
that fact where yusuke is only given
this one face to make all show kabara is
given the moon and back some scenes he's
angry and brooding swearing in to take
yusuke down some he sat and
contemplative thinking back on how he
let his gang down in the first episode
and in others he's delivering the best
comedic moments of the entire
adaptation there is so much life in this
character and I wish some of that would
have been imparted in you know the main
character okay moving on unfortunately I
must now address the elephant in the
room because breaking news these final
two episodes make a sincere attempt to
adapt the Dark Tournament across two
hours you heard me right and by Dark
Tournament I mean literally just three
fights and the final Togo Showdown I'm
serious well the action remains as
spectacular as it has been throughout
the entire show but the only issue is
that it's all just so vapid with no
insight into kurama's pass the battle
against kosu amounts to little more than
a bizarre furry eared spectacle he
struggles with the black dragon don't
exist so the moment against buoy is just
a big question mark I mean there's
really not a story going on here anymore
it's more of a greatest hit montage that
might look cool but is completely devoid
of the meaningful character work found
in the source material and well CGI max
power toguro kind of deletes a lot of
the Goodwill I was giving to its visual
front these episodes really just leave
me with a lingering question of who is
this actually written for there are
obviously only two types of people that
can watch this adaptation those who have
already seen or red YuYu Haka show and
those who haven't for existing fans of
the story so much is lost confused or
poorly executed in this back half that
as I mentioned earlier in the video it's
hard to imagine longtime YuYu Haka show
Faithful is falling in love with this so
much of what is beloved about this story
has been lost in Hasty translation hell
the Dark Tournament this series's most
popular Arc has been reduced down to
three fights and the big Togo battle the
approach devolved from a thoughtful
reimagining of an an existing story to a
story that is constantly tripping over
its own feet in an attempt to rapidly
cover every highlight it can think of
and that's not exactly enticing to
longtime fans and then there's the
newcomers to the franchise and I think
they may honestly be in an even worse
situation watching this the back half
operates at such a fast Cliff zooming
through characters and flock beats and
moments at break neck speeds that I
would honestly love to talk to someone
whose first introduction to YuYu Haka
show was through this show so so many
plot points character introductions and
developments go unexplained that I can't
imagine a newcomer watching this show
and going yeah that all made sense and
ultimately the final Conflict Stakes its
emotional core heavily upon you guessed
it Gen Kai the Crux of yusuke versus
toguro the final fight of this series
lays its fulcrum upon the character that
existed in this adaptation for about 7
Minutes of runtime with little to no
reason for audience attachment the
actual fight itself is well
choreographed much like the rest of the
show The spectacle is there but it is
just hard to feel invested in its
conflict when its components are so
flimsy so many pieces were in place for
this adaptation the action set design
most of the CG casting even they were
all top of their class compared to other
liveaction anime adaptations but it's
for that reason that I am so bummed
about how this story concluded Netflix
and robot Communications assembled a
cracked team of master chefs but asked
them to create a food that is both
breakfast lunch dinner dessert brunch
drink and condiments all at the same
time when it was 8 a.m. and all we
needed was
breakfast one of the most critically and
commercially panned anime adaptations to
be released in recent memory has to be
2021s lackluster adaptation of cowboy
bbop produced by tomorrow Studios the
production of that show produced stilted
action sequences awkward dialogue and
ultimately felt as though it entirely
missed the point of what fans of the
series series loved about it so much
films and TV shows are an enormous
investment and risk for Studios to
support perhaps now more than ever which
is why you've no doubt noticed an
enormous surge in the amount of
property-driven films and remakes
produced over the last decade I mean why
risk hundreds of Millions on a film with
an original idea when you can just
remake something with a built-in fan
base that you know will support your
investment through their shared love and
curiosity there's a reason that two of
the highest grossing films released this
year Mario and Barbie are both films
headlined by the most popular and
recognizable video game character and
toy line on Earth I mean just look at
the top 10 grossing films in history and
you'll see it's littered with popular
IPS that had themselves fan bases prior
to their film's initial conception this
is all to say that we are far from done
with this liveaction adaptation Trend
and I would argue we are on the cusp of
a truly fascinating Renaissance of these
older established anime stories remember
when I mentioned tomorrow studio just a
moment ago the production team which was
behind the likes of cowboy bop's
adaptation well did you know that that
very same studio produced another
adaptation recently and it was Netflix's
one piece live action okay but how can
this be why was there such an enormous
difference in the final result well in
short it believed in the story it was
trying to tell and that was all thanks
to one piece's showrunner Steve MAA who
not only respected The Source material
but treasured it I first noticed him as
a Creator when I was reviewing one piece
blind back in 2020 and he started to
follow me on Twitter through that I
noticed how he had followed other
creators covering that story and since
then it has come to light that he has
recruited the help of many Die Hard fans
and creators online to contribute in
some small or large ways to the
production this is of course all to say
that he was a genuine fan of One Piece
he valued what the fans valued and that
passion and respect for the story showed
up in the final product through the
production through the casting through
everything one piece has an enormous fan
base far larger than that which yuu Haka
show boasts but I can't help but feel
had YuYu Haka show been more patient
respected The Source material a little
more and tried to tell one great story
using the ingredients from the first
season we could have been looking at a
new standard Bearer but alas it fell
short one piece live action was a
massive commercial and critical success
one that captured the hearts of fans
across the world and although it didn't
grab me to the extent it did with others
I think what it and yuu Haka Show's
adaptations have proven is that 100%
success is possible we are very much on
the cusp of a brand new era of anime and
manga adaptations there will be for
certain some Growing Pains but I think
if one piece or yuu hacker show have
demonstrated anything is that the
ingredients are all there and perhaps
the future is brighter than many of us
ever thought possible thanks for
[Music]
watching